today's video i'm gonna be reacting to a
nucleus medical media animation all
about pcos now i want you all to keep in
mind that pcos is a complex disease and
affects everyone differently it's not
something that one size fits all let's
watch the video together and learn all
about pcos
polycystic ovary syndrome also called
pcos
is an imbalance of the female sex
hormones
the ovaries are part of the female
reproductive system
along with the fallopian tubes
uterus
and vagina
your ovaries contain your lifetime
supply of eggs
these eggs are immature and are stored
in tiny fluid-filled structures called
follicles
your pituitary gland located at the base
of the brain produces hormones that
direct the function of your ovaries
each month the pituitary gland secretes
follicle stimulating hormone or fsh and
luteinizing hormone or lh into the
bloodstream
i love already that this is
demonstrating what pcos actually is and
i always like to emphasize this pcos is
a syndrome whenever we talk about
syndromes that's going to refer to
something that affects multiple organ
systems in the body it's called
polycystic ovarian syndrome but it's not
just about the ovaries as you can see it
also affects the pituitary that's
located in the brain after these
hormones reach the ovaries
several hundred immature eggs start to
mature
expanding the size of the follicles
as the eggs mature the follicles secrete
estrogen the main female sex hormone
once the amount of estrogen in the blood
reaches a certain level
the pituitary sends a surge of
luteinizing hormone
to the ovaries
causing the most mature follicle to open
and release its egg in a process called
ovulation
the free egg travels through the
fallopian tube where it awaits
fertilization
eventually the remaining immature
follicles and eggs dissolve
i love that it gave a very brief
overview of the menstrual cycle all the
different hormones that are in play
hormones made in the ovary like estrogen
and also hormones made in the brain like
fsh and lh
now i think they're probably going to
jump into pcos and what goes differently
during pcos if the egg is not fertilized
the egg and the lining of the uterus are
shed now they're dripping out
but i think it's coming next if you have
polycystic ovary syndrome your pituitary
gland may release abnormally high
amounts of luteinizing hormone into your
bloodstream
disrupting your normal menstrual cycle
as a result your follicles do not mature
and ovulation does not occur which can
lead to infertility
some of the immature follicles do not
dissolve and remain as fluid-filled sacs
or cysts
so this is one of the reasons why it's
called polycystic ovarian syndrome
those little immature follicles they
stay inside of the egg and then when we
do an ultrasound it's like we see tiny
little follicles all around the outside
of the ovary but they're immature none
of them are maturing or ovulating the
immature follicles do not dissolve and
remain as fluid-filled sacs or cysts
in addition your doctor may find your
blood has high levels of insulin
a hormone produced by the pancreas
too much insulin combined with high
levels of luteinizing hormone
can lead to excess production of a male
hormone
called testosterone in your ovaries
abnormally high levels of testosterone
prevent ovulation which can lead to
infertility
so i like that they're involving the
high levels of insulin that's seen with
pcos this is why people that have pcos
are at an increased risk of developing
type 2 diabetes high levels of
testosterone also cause many of the
physical features associated with
polycystic ovary syndrome such as acne
and abnormal hair growth
having polycystic ovary syndrome raises
your risk for type 2 diabetes because of
excess insulin and insulin resistance
heart disease
high blood pressure
cholesterol abnormalities in the blood
and endometrial cancer
remember how i said this is a syndrome
that can affect different organ systems
this is what i'm talking about since
there is no cure for polycystic ovary
syndrome your doctor may recommend one
or more medications to treat your
symptoms such as
hormonal birth control which while
preventing pregnancy also regulates your
menstrual cycle and reduces testosterone
production in your ovaries
anti-androgen by reducing that
testosterone in your ovaries you're also
going to see improvement of acne and
facial hair growth stuff like that
medications which reduce abnormal hair
growth and acne
diabetes medications such as metformin
which lowers your insulin levels and
regulates your menstrual cycle
and fertility medications which can
stimulate ovulation so you can become
pregnant
if you want to become pregnant this mean
that every single person that has pcos
has to undergo fertility medication or
fertility treatments
no not necessarily make sure you're
talking to your doctor about you
specifically if you want to become
pregnant and fertility medications have
not succeeded in restoring ovulation
your doctor may recommend laparoscopic
ovarian drilling
during the procedure your surgeon will
insert a small needle into the ovary and
use an electric current
to destroy small areas of ovarian tissue
where testosterone is produced
over time testosterone production
diminishes and ovulation may occur
i will never get over how amazing these
animations are truly nucleus medical
media it's amazing i know they talked
about a lot of different medications and
treatment options and even that ovarian
drilling but if you have pcos like i
said in the beginning this is not a
disease that one size fits all so you
may not be a candidate for the drilling
or maybe you're not a candidate for some
other medication so always make sure
that you're talking to your doctor about
what works best for you i hope you guys
enjoyed this video i love making these
reaction videos because the animation is
truly fascinating they're shorter videos
they're easy to understand i'm a visual
learner so i love it this video has been
a collaboration between nucleus medical
media and my youtube channel alirodmd on
my youtube channel i've created a fun
space where i can talk about all things
women's health if you want to check out
my channel i'm going to leave a link in
the description below alright everybody
i hope you have an amazing day always
remember to be kind and show love to
everyone around you i'll see you guys in
the next one bye